all right now a medley I'm a little bit
late to this party but I have finally
seen guardians of the galaxy now I don't
really want to take up your time doing a
review of a movie that's already been
out for more than two weeks but seeing
the movie does make me want to talk
about some things about the Marvel
Universe in general specifically some
things about it that kind of have me a
little worried now before I get down
this road let me just say guardians of
the galaxy was a ton of fun and I have
no doubt it is going to be for an entire
generation a better analog for Star Wars
than the actual new Star Wars movies are
going to end up being now I am going to
be talking spoilers for guardians and
for every other Marvel movie that's come
out so far so you've been warned that's
out of the way let's do this every good
thing you've heard about guardians the
galaxy is true but if there's one
sticking point you find consistently
it's that people tend to save the
villains a little weak Lee pace is
running the accuser he looks the part
he's intimidating enough but really it's
very cut and paste it's very insert
world-destroying guy here and everything
kind of brought to my attention the fact
that the Marvel movies have a little bit
of a villain problem going on right now
quick name a memorable villain from any
of the phase two movies no sorry Loki
does not count he was introduced in
phase one and your time is up see what I
mean it's odd because in a way the fact
that the latest crop of Marvel villains
have been more or less than or
changeable is actually partly and
doodled stuff they're doing really well
which is that they do the heroes
fantastically it's kind of the opposite
of what is often a criticism of the
Batman franchises which is the villains
are so interesting that they overshadow
the heroes now really if you're going to
have one outshine the other you're
better off having the hero outside the
villa especially if you're here is we're
going to stick around trying to build
some bigger universe but I really do
feel that Marvel is getting complacent
with this template that they started
using cuz really Ronan is the exact same
villain that Malekith from thor the dark
world was the only real difference is
that Ronan gets just a little bit more
motivational explanation he wants to
destroy this planet because he's out for
revenge and it may be a religious thing
to its kind of implied Malekith wanted
to destroy the universe because that's
what Dark Elves do I guess it's very
obviously that they're using the same
mannequin and just dressing him in
different clothes let's be fair Marvel
has hit it out of the park before with
the
miss that is loki but even that's
starting to become a little bit of a
problem too because he's become so
popular they had to make him kind of an
antihero in the second Thor movie and
even though there's stuff that goes on
at the end of that that it's obvious
he's got to still be in villain status
marble is never going to kill him he's
too popular and then it's almost like it
becomes dr. evil in a way that's kind of
the problem with villains when you're
building a larger franchise you either
keep them around for so long that they
become as popular as the heroes and you
can never kill them which you should be
able to do with a villain or you kill
them at the end of every story and then
you just start getting into that trouble
of they become very copy-paste Marvel
somehow is managing to do both these
things now I haven't given up hope on
all this obviously we've got Ultron
waiting to see that could work and
despite my earlier reservations I
actually really liked what josh brolin
brought to Thanos in the two scenes that
he had in guardians he's got this little
bit of suave to him that just your
generic booming voice actor wouldn't
have brought to the part so I'll be
excited to see him come back and also
guardians wasn't a total loss either
because we had Karen Gillan as nebula
and on paper this character really thin
but she did a lot in her performance
just finding motivations and with little
expressions in the way she delivered
lines she brought a lot of depth to that
character I'm actually really glad they
didn't kill her although that actually
brings me to my second point and that
would be the lack of death or more
accurately the lack of permanent death
for anybody aside from villains look
it's one thing for the heroes to live
that's actually par for the course in
any sort of Hollywood franchise it's
another thing to go oh they're dead nah
haha fooled you and then bring them back
Marbles pulled this trick on audiences
five times now they did it with Phil
Coulson Nick Fury Bucky Barnes Loki and
now brute look the thing of GRU
regrowing from a cutting of himself I
was prepared to give that a pass because
it does come out of the comic books but
it's
what pattern I just can't ignore any
isolated case of where they do this it's
fine unto itself but it's just it's the
repeat use of this you start adding
these all up and it starts a little
dangerously like Marvel comic books or
comic books in general because in comic
books nobody ever stays dead and if they
keep bringing that on board with the
movies then when they actually do decide
to kill somebody even if it's somebody
important it's gonna lose all its weight
because audiences are going to be going
oh yeah sure you killed him when's he
coming back come on comic book reduced
used to say nobody stays dead except for
Bucky Jason Todd and Uncle Ben you know
what they don't say that anymore why
because two out of three of those have
since been brought back to life Marvel
Studios has already pushes the point
that I can't take any death seriously
the only notable character death had
stuck so far has been Freya Thor's mom I
suppose if you want you can count
Yeltsin from the first iron man I don't
personally because it's very clear that
he's not gonna make it through the end
of this there was nothing shocking about
that death stop pretending to kill
people or kill them and let them stay
dead as eventually they're going to come
around to a point where they need to
kill somebody permanently and they have
to and be able to have us take that
seriously specifically I figure it's
going to be Chris Evans as Captain
America because he's made it very clear
that once his contract is up he does not
want to continue making these movies are
really acting at all and Marvel Studios
seems to be anticipating that because
they've introduced two characters who
have both taken off the mantle of
Captain America in the comics in Steve
Rogers absence the thing is though for
my money that doesn't happen till
Avengers 3 so we've got between now and
then to establish that death has meaning
and relevance finally I want to touch on
the Stinger at the end of the credits
for a couple of reasons people seem
really split on this particular one
which involved a joke with Howard the
Duck some people thought it was
hilarious which I did some people were
confused by because they had no idea who
Howard the Duck was and some people were
ticked off by it because they SAT
through all these credits and all they
got was a joke no building of a larger
universe no teasing for what's coming
next just a joke but come on let's be
serious there have only been two credit
stingers that have had any real
important meaning the introduction of
nick fury at the end of Iron Man and the
you love fan knows mid-credits on
Avengers that's it the rest of them you
don't need they were just kind of tossed
in there I have no problem with them
using it as a joke that said some people
have actually now started asking does
this mean we're getting Howard the Duck
movie no I really don't think that's the
case but it does make me wonder does
Marvel think they can get away with
anything because it's become a bit of a
joke with guardians being as big as it
is even though it's really good people
say oh well they could just sell us any
character now because of how little
known guardians were wasn't a bankable
name but they made a great very
successful movie out of it and I really
hope that Marvel doesn't start to buy
into that hype themselves I'm worried
about that specifically with what looks
like their next big announce project
which is the Inhumans now I will admit
to not knowing a ton about the Inhumans
but the more I look into it the more I
find out the more I'm kind of like guys
can we leave this one alone cuz here's
the thing yes guardians is made up of
characters that nobody knows and are
really painfully ridiculous but it fills
a niche that was not currently covered
by its other projects cuz that's thing
while all these characters they share
universe and they share a general feel
they're all filling different niches
with the individual franchises they're
all action movies to a certain extent
but I remain you've got the more sci-fi
bend to it Thor feels the fantasy neesh
Captain America has failed multiple
niches initially would sort of a
nostalgic old timey war movie and then
with a political thriller and now
garnish the galaxy is filling sort of
that space opera star wars tighten them
feel to it but exactly what niche is the
Inhumans gonna fill it just makes me
concerned and I we heard a little bit
since then that it seems like Kevin
figis idea is that that's sort of gonna
sort of be Marvel's substitute for the
x-men because Fox has the rights to all
those and I can see what there's a
certain validity to that you know you
deal with issues of sort of acceptance
and finding your place in the world by
these people who were just born this way
and they can't help it but then it seems
like they're they're chasing fox's tail
a little bit it would be one thing if
the x-men franchise was badly flagging
but it's been very well revitalize din
recent years and Marvel kind of doing
this oh we wish we had the x-men well
what's the closest thing we got them
selves the rights to oh we can do the
Inhumans I don't like that because what
part of what's been great about marvel
all this is they are the leaders in this
movie comic book industry and the other
thing about the Inhumans if they use
them similar to how x-men gets use we're
now suddenly they can have a ton of
characters that they don't have to
justify where they got their powers from
that really does risk them flooding the
universe with too many super-powered
characters I mean let us not forget
they've had to cull the herd several
times in the comic books with the legacy
virus decimation they get overloaded
with these guys and it could very easily
happen in the movies if they're not
really careful about it let me be clear
I'm not saying Marvel's headed down the
wrong path of that their movie suddenly
suck I'm just saying that I'm noticing
these patterns that they worry me and
their patterns that I really want to see
Marvel either break away from her find a
way to subvert because if they keep
going down the path that they've set
it's gonna start to unravel on them but
I have a pretty good amount of faith in
them that they're well aware enough that
some of these things if not all of them
will get corrected but I just got to get
my feelings out there and my concerns
maybe you share them maybe you think I'm
crazy you know what at this point we've
got ten Marvel movies that have hit
theaters so out of the ten what is your
personal favorite Marvel movie drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned